You. So thank you. Thank you. We'll now move into the
patient, overly patient It department,
as we are now officially 55 minutes over.
But I'm sure Director Kent will make up for that 55 minutes
of lost time.
Am I on? So,
good afternoon. Good afternoon.
As mayor pro Tim Martin indicated, I am Lisa Kent.
I am the city's chief information officer and the director
of the Houston It. Services Department. With me.
Here is William Bryant. William was introduced
first by Director Emo. He is the department
fiscal Administrator assigned to Hits. He is a member of the finance organization.
Will serves in a CFO like function for my department.
And I also want to acknowledge the two financial analysts that support
Will. One of them is here today. That's herbert Gardner. He's raising his
hand back there. And the other one is Curia askew. She's out of
the office today, so she's not present. So together, this team
of three helps manage a very large and complex
budget for the Hits department. And I want to thank them
for helping me prepare this presentation and all the data associated
with it. I also want to give a huge shout out to the Hits executive
team. They are not here. They are busy working on all the projects that support
you and our customers. But I will acknowledge them
in the next few slides and give you a little flavor for what
they do in our organization. Many of you, in fact,
most of you, have met all of my direct reports and know them from
either Cyber or TTI presentations. And I
know you know how proud I am of them, each one of them personally,
as well as for the professional work that they do for the city of Houston
each and every day. So with that, let's get started, and we'll go to the
next slide.
So the proposed fiscal year 23 budget for
Hits is $98,051,415.
Hits budget is entirely a central services revolving
fund, which means that the funding we spend
is charged back to those departments who consume our services.
And that chargeback shows up in each of those department budgets
under their restricted accounts. Our FY 23
budget includes the funding for 210.6 positions.
Please note that the FTE funded account amount
for the previous year FY 22 was 202 positions,
with a vacancy factor of around 7.4%.
This FY 23 increase in the funded FTEs
is due to the consolidation of It personnel from
three different departments. So these are not net new positions.
They are positions that are moving from one department into the other.
For FY 23, we did choose to increase our vacancy factor
to approximately 7.77%.
The decision to do that was made in consideration not only
of the economic conditions, but specifically
from the significant challenges that we're encountering in the It
market and that is adversely impacting our ability
to recruit It professionals. You may recall Director
Emo referenced the great resignation in her initial presentation.
This is certainly something that is impacting it everywhere.
It is not a problem that is unique to the City of Houston.
I am a member of the Inspire Houston CIOs group
for the city of the Houston regional area. I regularly
talk and visit with CIOs from all parts of the business,
including private sector, and every single one of us
is facing this challenge. And so this is something that is
not unique to City of Houston government. Looking department
wide below that first chart. This body of
the slide shows the distribution of funds and personnel across seven key areas
within our department. You can see the breakdown of budget and personnel
for each of those areas. I'm not going to read this chart, but it's there
for your reference. So, next slide.
Now let's go through those key functions. I'm going to do this quickly in a
more abbreviated fashion than I would normally have done. But I do want to start
out that at the Director's office level, as the CIO for the City of
Houston, I am responsible for It strategic planning and
It governance. In addition to that, we have the amazing
Dr. Jane Wu, who is assistant director for our Resource Management
division. She's responsible for those additional functions underneath.
Next, the cybersecurity team is led by the city's Chief Information
Security Officer, who is another incredibly talented
and powerful leader. That's Dr. Christopher Mitchell. And yes, we do
have two PhDs as part of my Direct Reports team.
We're very proud of that. Chris is responsible for
those things that you see listed below. I do want to emphasize
that for FY 23, we will be beginning our efforts to
develop the next four year Master plan. And the focus
of that going forward will be building an infrastructure
with a zero trust model. And so council member Cayman
in advance. I know you're going to be asking the question, what are
ways that you guys can support us or unmet needs? We are
always going to ask for additional support and additional funding
for our cybersecurity program. So you'll hear
more from us in the private briefings that we address with you and where
we educate you a little bit on what we're facing and what we're doing about
it. Transitioning to
Enterprise infrastructure services. The Deputy CIO position
for this functional area is currently vacant. However, we are
very blessed to have two strong and capable leaders underneath
that vacant position. And so those two groups are
the network and telecom services group, led by Assistant Director Anthony
Evigan and the Compute services, led by Assistant Director
Burke Corford. This is our largest organization, as you can
see from the Plier side, both on dollars and on
positions. And so you can take a look later at all the amazing
things that they do and to keep the city running.
Next slide. Next is Public
Safety Communications, and this is led by a very strong technical
leader, and that is Assistant Director Nick Curran, one of the things that's
not listed in this description. So just a feel for scale.
We support over 18,000 radios within the
city of Houston. Those are largely police and fire. They're a
combination of handheld or portable radios in
addition to the in car or mobile radios.
Besides those 18,000, we also support 6600
radios, for which we sell those services to
more than 30 greater Houston regional partners.
And then these last three programming areas are all led by Summer Shao.
Summer is one of the real transformational forces on our
Direct Reports team. We couldn't do our job without
her and her capable folks. She is responsible for those.
Next three. I'm not going to read each one of them, but I will point
out that Enterprise Application Services
encompasses ERP, which Council Member Kubosh,
I know you sometimes ask me about acronyms that is essentially Enterprise
Resources Management and Planning is our SAP
platform. So that's our financial procurement and HR system.
That group also includes data management, enterprise, GIS,
analytics and so forth. And then client management solutions.
Those are CSMART. That's the courts where my
team maintains the system that Judge Marshall's organization
uses to operate her business. And then finally we have
the Hits It Project Management Group, which works on project governance,
scope development metrics, and so forth to help us ensure that those projects
meet the expected outcomes. Next slide.
So there aren't any direct statutes that require us to implement
specific electronic systems. However, all of the city departments
that you hear from depend on Hits in order to implement
their business, and many of them do have statutory requirements to
conduct certain services. These three cyber statutes
listed below, I'm not going to go through each one of them, but I know
that you recognize HIPAA and PCI and security sensitive
information that affects our airport system. Next slide.
In terms of societal impact, again,
all city departments depend on us. We have
several stats listed there that you can read through that give you a feel for
the scale of what we support. At the bottom of the chart,
I did list just a few examples of citizen facing services,
and we had planned to share some statistics with you. I can get those to
you offline if you're interested. But Council Member Kubosh,
one of those was infor, as a matter of fact, for dawn statistics
about how much they use that platform for.
Next slide. So let's talk about funding.
This is the second fiscal year that Hits is budgeted completely in the
revolving fund. Therefore, all of our expenses are revolved back
or charged back to the city department customers. The chargeback
is seen as an expense again in their restricted accounts, but it's
offsetting as revenue for my department. And so therefore,
this table that you see on this chart represents
a revenue table, and it matches the expenditures table
that you'll see on the next slide. These amounts will always be the same.
We have to zero out our budget at the end of the year.
Thank you. So the revenue highlights. Again,
most of our revenue comes back, but here's a couple of unique revenues that we
generate that you might not know about. The first is the Verizon Wireless Rebate
in FY 22. Actual revenues already collected is a million dollars.
Of that, 794,000 went to the General
Government Revenue Fund, 43,000 went to the Houston Airport
System and 163,000 went to Houston Public
Works. Another cool revenue source is that radio revenue
that I talked about. That will be $1.9 million by
the time we end this fiscal year. And again, that is
booked to the city's general Revenue Fund. Next slide.
So, expenditures. This chart represents a historical view of
our expenditures. The variance column over to the right,
second to last, shows you the comparison of FY 23
to FY 22 adopted budget. As you can see, that variance is
10.8% and I'll go into some details about that on the
next slide.
So the overall proposed budget we are submitting again is 98,051,000
in change. Of that only 31% is for
personnel. 69% of our budget is for services
and supplies that provide those products and services
to other departments. The pie chart on the right is that
nonpersonal breakdown. That 69%. And so one
thing that's important to note over the past few years we've made significant
progress in benchmarking our expenses to similar It
organizations of like size and function. And so
one of the things that you'll notice in this presentation is we are using
those same categories that align with the Gartner It budget
tool that we use for benchmarking. I'll start with this chart
with traditional software and I'll move clockwise around that particular
chart. Traditional software makes up 24%
of our expenditures and that represents software that is installed physically
on our equipment in our data centers. The next one is SaaS
or Software as a service that makes up 16%.
And SaaS is an example of a vendor provided and maintained product
in the cloud. An example would be Office 365.
The next 15% includes expenses related to
education, training and supplies to support our operations.
The next one is transport. Transport portion represents
21% and that is projected expenses for mobile,
fixed data and voice services, citywide pass
or platform as a service along with other public cloud.
And Is which is infrastructure as a service. Those represent
a combined 2% and they are public cloud management and
security services. In simpler terms, those are the
things where we use a vendor's infrastructure and that is shared
so that we get improved economies of scale and flexibility for
scaling up and scaling down very quickly. Examples of that would be
Azure or Amazon Web Services. Next.
The 17% is allocated to traditional outsourcing
and they are the fees that we pay for consultants and managed
services where we may hire a company to do a service for
us like communications, cabling or portions of
our telecom infrastructure. And then the final category is 5% for
hardware. One important point to note on that, we do buy
a lot of hardware through our capital improvement budget. So it's not surprising
that hardware is a lower percentage in the operating budget. Next slide.
Now I would like to highlight some of the net changes in
the proposed FY 23 budget over FY 22.
The first item you will see again that we are
consolidating resources. Five of those FTEs
are coming from the Houston Health Department in the
infrastructure area. Three are from Houston Public Works.
That is part of our consolidation of cybersecurity for that department.
Those are moving under dr. Chris Mitchell. And then the last one
is in Legal, a partial consolidation. And those
folks that one individual physician is moving under our infrastructure team.
So together these combined are 1.34 million.
Again moving into my department from another department.
Secondly, you can see the hope increases for approximately
846,000 increase over last year's budget.
Next you'll see two net new initiatives. Those expenditure
lines have been submitted for approval to the administration.
These dollars support the maintenance of our open data portal and
also new radio security services which
is going to help us protect our radio system
from malicious software and other malicious activity.
And finally, the restricted accounts for Hits consist of allocations Hits
receives from other departments such as Ara, Human Resources,
Finance and Planning. So in summary, we have a 10.8% increase.
I will highlight the key portions of that increase on the upcoming slide.
So I won't go over it consolidation again, but I will move down
to some of what you'll see in our budget is a realignment of expenses.
So for example, Director Emo referenced Hits is the
pilot department. We are always up for a challenge and being
the guinea pig for the city to try things first. And so as part of
that initiative, we went through and looked at one of the areas we needed to
separate from one cost center into two was our end
user Compute support services. So that's just dividing those into two
cost centers and that will also help us with cleaner chargeback.
Another example of Realignment is in the data management area.
This is another one council member Kubosh asked me about.
We hired the Edo, which is the Enterprise data Officer his name
is Raphael Luvre. And when we did that hire,
we did realign the expenses of the resources that now can report
up under that separate cost center for those functions. I also want
to point out that the hiring of the Edo helped us as
a city accomplish one of the actions required by the
Resilient Houston plan. That's action number 44.1.
And then finally on Realignments we are also adjusting
costs between Esignature and managed print services.
So in further support of Resilient Houston and the climate action plan.
We are driving print costs down and we are encouraging
an increased usage of Esignature. So more
electronic processing, less printing
transitioning. Let's talk about Microsoft.
Last August, Microsoft announced that they
would be rolling out a substantive price increase across the
board to all Office 365 subscribers. That's global.
Okay? We were grandfathered in. That's why it did not affect my budget in
FY 22. We were still under the current Enterprise
agreement where the pricing was locked. However, next month
I will be coming to the TTI committee to present to you the
proposed new three year enterprise agreement for the city and
that will incorporate the price increase as
well as an upgrade in features that we will be requesting.
So you'll hear a lot more from me about what's involved in those prices.
But just a little preview, that's part of what
is included in our FY 23 budget.
And then next, we've already discussed a little bit about the job market and the
great resignation. One of the things that we had to include in our budget
for FY 23, we noticed the most significant
attrition in our ERP group. Again, that's our SAP support
function. And so we did submit as part of our budget
to augment that ERP team. That addresses the concern
that we're having not only with retirement and attrition, but the
difficulty in the extended periods of time it's taking us to recruit,
to backfill. And then finally in the cybersecurity
insurance sector, this continues to diminish
as more providers vacate that space. That results
in an increase in premiums and it also results
in a reduction of coverage. And so that's something that you
will hear more from us about in some of the private briefings.
And so there you have it. That is a summary of the FY 23 expenditure
changes. This concludes my presentation.
I do want to invite you to browse through the appendix. There are
a lot of documents back there that talk about not only our organization,
but also our strategic priorities,
challenges with technological debt,
and our FY 22 accomplishments. So with that, I'll be glad
to take your questions. Thank you, Director Kent. Council Member Michael Kubosh.
Thank you very much, Director Kent. I appreciate your biweekly
report for the Open Finance. The cybersecurity
that you have us take online is
extremely helpful to people like me that I
wasn't born with a mouse in my hand. So I've
learned a lot from those cyber security courses.
I appreciate you giving us advanced notice on rates
and rate increases and things that we have to purchase because it used to just
give this council shell shock when we'd see these things
appear. Do we get federal grants to help
us to pay for cybersecurity? Is there anything available that
may help us to mitigate the cost of some of these things?
Yes, sir. We do get federal grant money through UASI, and that
is granted through the City's Department of
homeland Security under Chief Eunuch. What we get
from them is largely training. We do
seek to get more money, and we have been lobbying federal legislatures,
legislators, to help us have the federal
government release more cybersecurity money to actually buy
product and services. Now, I do expect to see
that in some of the new federal bills. We have not yet
seen it trickle down, but you might see that in the infrastructure bill once
it's finally announced. I would like to see updated times where
you give us this mandatory cybersecurity
training because I think it's really needed and I
really do appreciate it. Thank you. Thank you, council Member Abby Cayman.
Thank you, Mayor. Pro TEM director. I think you know where
my questions are going to be, are going to go towards but I
think it's startling. A lot of the budget presentations
we see personnel is the major cost.
You don't see that with it. I think that's two things, but correct me if
I'm wrong. One, we don't have a lot of personnel
in the department. I work with Dr. Mitchell and you a lot. I don't know
how he does everything that he does. He is incredible.
But it's also the cost of this type of equipment, the technological
cost, that, again, a lot of it's behind the scenes, but it's
necessary to keep the city safe.
I know that we cannot in a public realm discuss a lot
as it relates to Homeland Security concerns,
cyber concerns, but we have seen some of the more public hacks
and things like that that have occurred. For example, Kronos was
something that actually didn't impact us as much as it did other businesses,
but still had an impact that wasn't against city infrastructure.
But given the current
dynamics, the war in Ukraine, other issues,
where are we as a city, just generally speaking, in terms of
coming into moving beyond the last century,
in terms of technology upgrades here?
Thank you for asking that question. I will give you a measured
response. We can provide and do
provide a lot of detailed information to
you, city council members, and obviously to Mayor Turner that are
very specific about what the city faces from a cybersecurity
perspective. What I will say publicly
is that with
your support, we have been making tremendous
strides. One of the things that you will see spoken
about publicly with anyone talking about
cybersecurity is the need for a layered defense
strategy. And so no matter which
entity you talk to, government or private sector alike,
they will all tell you we're always going to need to
do more. Okay? And so what we need
you to understand is much to Council Member Kubosh's
comment, that it takes everybody, it takes the employees
to be security conscious, and it takes us to put
many layers of defense in there simply to have
a fighting chance at slowing down the adversary. I could
be put back in queue. Go ahead,
last one. You're the only one. All right, I'll hurry up because I know
people want a quick break for lunch, if we can. Not yet,
no, keep driving.
I was just at a roundtable conversation this morning
with FEMA. So we're talking about the federal dollars that we need
to draw down upon. And we were talking with different colleagues
around the country about what keeps us up at night,
and cybersecurity redundancy is what keeps
me up at night. But also, Council Member
Peck and I talk a lot about this other council members, our CAD system,
other needs that are just so high
in terms of price tag that we as a city cannot afford without those investments.
We have CAD. That is a need. Are there other needs that we should be
aware of right now as it relates to those
It assets
that we can speak about publicly? Yes. If you would
flip to page 20, which is in the appendix section.
There's a chart there that gives you a feel for the scale.
When we talk about technical debt or technological
debt, we're talking about systems that no
different than what Director Haddock spoke about with her infrastructure
for water and sewer. The city has infrastructure,
both hardware and software applications that we have to maintain.
And when you don't replace those often enough, you create
a vulnerability, which translates
to risk. Those equipments either get old and
they don't function as well as they used to, or they are
no longer supported by the manufacturer. And therefore, that translates into a cyber
risk. So this chart, that's worth looking at. If you
look on the right hand side of the page, it shows you what our five
year citywide CIP is. The only
thing not included in that is the Houston Airport systems.
Separate CIP and Houston Public Works. Separate CIP.
But otherwise, that number of 39,000,500 is
the five year number for years 22 through 26 for
capital investment in technology. The left hand side
of the column is only the top six projects
that we need funding for. Really? Four and a
half of those six are public safety technology related.
So in terms of what is needed, the city
needs more spending capacity to deal with
public safety technology equipment. And the ones that I've listed
there are HPD Radio refresh,
the HPD Records Management System network refresh,
which I'm saying is partially public safety related CAD, which you
just asked about $17 million. The only one that
is wholly not public safety related is the SAPS for
Hana upgrade. But at the top, there is
CSMART, where we need to do some continued technology refresh.
And that does have some public safety implications with that system
as well. So these monies, you can tell the
dramatic skewing of what's available versus what
is needed just for the top six. No,
and I appreciate that highlight. And just for those in
the public that are listening, when we talk about records Management systems
with HPD. That sounds very basic, but there's certain data that we cannot
even track right now, including when a crime involves
a gun, whether that gun was stolen, whether it was obtained
legally. We cannot track any of that right now,
even though we're dealing with astronomical levels of gun violence. So all these basic
things, right, that we think as a city we should be able to do,
we are having challenges with. So I just appreciate your
department. Again, so much of it goes back to Public Safety.
I don't know how you do and your team do all the things that you
do do, but recognizing the budgetary
limitations that we are continuing to face right now.
Thank you. So, Director Cant, one thing
struck me and one thing only in your budget. So 22 to
23, you have an interdepartmental credit
for 1.3 million. Without that, you're 34 million
less than what you spent last year.
Right. So you had 88 you -1.3 you're at
98. Because you had interdepartmental
consolidations of FTE. Can you put some color around that?
Because I look at it and I go at 1.34 million.
That's 18 employees at $75,000.
So I'm assuming we're going to see the appropriate
debit from Public Works,
which we didn't see because I just looked through their notes.
Legal and HHD,
you're getting the people, but the flow of funds isn't following you.
It is following you. But the appropriate debit isn't coming out of their
department's expense. That's right. Because they continue to pay for those resources
that are dedicated to them. So what is a little bit confusing about we added
1.3 to your budget on the increase.
Yes. What is confusing about the way the revolving funds
work is the money has to be on both sides of the fence.
So for me to have the control of those
positions and the money to fund them, it has
to show up in my revolving fund budget. It also
has to show up on their side of the house in their restricted account.
And so when I charge them back, it goes back.
So I'm looking for I see your credit of 1.3.
I don't see their debit of 1.3 or whatever theirs is for their individual
department, but their debit will be in their restricted account. In the
restricted account. So all of our expenses are budget within the department's
restricted accounts. So that slide where like on our
slide number 15, where you have a list of all the inner
fund restrictive accounts, we would charge them back.
Okay. Why are you assuming I'm going to say 75,000.
That's 18 people. Why are you assuming 18 people into your
department? What's going on? We're not assuming
18 individuals who we're absorbing nine, plus their
hope increases. Okay, so you're absorbing their salary?
Yes, only their salary, but not their reporting accountability.
We're absorbing their reporting reporting structure as well.
So who do they report to? Do they report to hits.
Yes. In fact, that's one of the reasons why we do that, because if we
leave the money exclusively in their budget, where they have the ability to choose
to spend it on something else, I love the fact that
your department is more of a centralized function. I hate decentralized function
organizations. That's a massive screw up. You're just waiting
for some bad things to happen. So I'm a big fan of what you did.
Okay, great. Because I believe they should be reporting to you even though they're
housed in another department. But I just wanted to see where they corresponded.
Like Mayor Turner says, hey, you can raise the budget,
but tell me where you're going to get the money. Well, you raised your money
by 1.3 million, and you didn't
tell me where it came from, because I looked back on one of the departments
that already presented. The other two are later, and they didn't have the corresponding
debit. It's restricted.
So we'll ask Legal and we'll ask Houston
Health when they come. So. Thank you, council Member Sally Alcorn.
Are there some other departments that you think would benefit from
being consolidated in, or have you swept everybody in that you need to?
We definitely have that's a loaded question.
There are definitely opportunities, and some of those opportunities are already
in discussion with those directors. I wouldn't want to say that
publicly, but there are definitely opportunities for that.
Yes. Great. Thanks. You all
do a great job. Thank you. Day in and day out. I appreciate what you
do. I'm sorry. We have four public
speakers. We'll start out with Mr. Doug Smith,
star six. Doug,
can you hear me? Yes, sir. Yes.
Okay, good. To follow up on the last comment,
relative to are you going to when you look through
the budget, you see lots of departments that have what I would call
hit related expenses, and I guess you're in the process
of trying to sweep all of those in as
much as possible. One that just came from this morning is Houston
Public Works. They show $20 million for computer related
expenses. So I'm glad to hear you're in the process of trying to rope
everybody in. And one final question.
Why did the salary for HFD support account
50 00:10 increased by 50%?
And also regarding that, do you provide any kind of similar support to
the Houston Police Department? Okay.
Mr. Smith, the reason why you see the increase in the HFD personnel once
we've gone through the exercise of looking at the EIS
compute call center, basically, we took those individuals that were
dedicated to HFD and moved those to the HFD call
center. So that's why you see that increase in personnel. So the
support level has not changed, but we did move the position,
so therefore the dollars will be in the correct funding structure.
Okay. Do you do similar support for Houston Police Department as
well? No, we. Do not.
The Houston Police Department is what we consider to
be a Federated It organization, which means they
have a Chief Technology Officer and a sizable It
organization. So what my department provides to
HPD are the Enterprise services, which is a
whole lot of things, but there are many services that they still do
themselves out of that technology budget. So they will have both a
restricted account chargeback from my department as well
as a separate It budget for their own.
Thank you. Mr. Why do they have a mr.
Oliver. Jason Oliver.
Thanks for interrupting.
Thank you. Hi. Thank you all
for the presentation. The budget was amended last year,
item 6.34, to include an online portal for
people to sign up for public session. I wanted to check in on
if that has been implemented or if we can get a target
completion date.
We were just conferring, Mr. Oliver. I'm not sure that
that particular amendment was actually approved, but what
I can tell you, we do have a project underway that is currently in
the planning phase. It won't be implemented until later in FY
23, but that is to upgrade the system that the
city council uses for City council agenda.
And so our thought is that we would be using that same platform to
allow the digital sign up of speakers. Now, one thing
in addition to that that we have also been doing is to
utilize tool sets that we already have to encourage the city secretary's
office to leverage things like teams and SharePoint that
as people sign up. That can be done on those existing tools, but we
do have plans to enhance it for the future. Okay, and then can
you share more about what on page eleven,
the open data portal support means, and then how often we
can expect to see updates in the future? I also want to say thank you
all. After last year, you all updated and
made the open data portal accessible again, which was really appreciated.
So thank you for that. We're just checking in about what that means. So you
just answered my question, your own question. So we were having a lot
of problems with that open data portal where, if you may recall, it would go
offline. That is a legacy application
that we needed some additional support. And so the money
that we built in as an ad to our budget was to outsource that
additional support until we could simply redesign it.
So the redesign of that open data portal is planned for FY 23
as well. Thank you. Doing that support I'm
sorry, who's offering that support? How is
that working? I don't recall the name of the vendor off the
top of my head. I can get back to you offline about that, but it
is a vendor consultant that is assisting us with that. Got you. Thank you,
Ms. Planning. As Ms. Planning walks up, so are we moving away from Novus
there is a project to upgrade Novus. So what
the solution will be is yet to be determined whether it continues
to be the evolution of Novus or another product. Thank you.
Hey, thank you for your presentation.
Lots of helpful explanations in there. I have two questions for
you. I noticed almost 60% of the top technological
needs you listed, I believe it was in the appendix,
belong to HPD improvements. And I was curious as to how these priorities
were made, especially after you explained that HPD kind of has
their own It. And then what are other priorities
that aren't listed that you would consider a high priority?
And then the second question is management consulting services
has increased dramatically from last fiscal year, now 3 million
from about 1 million. And what is the reason for that jump?
Okay, so Will is going to help keep me straight on the questions in order,
but let's talk first about this chart, the technological debt.
Okay, so HPD participates along
with all the other city departments, excluding airports
and public works in the citywide,
technology, CIP. So these are all investments that would be capital projects
and they are a part of that solution pool or the
group that considers those. The considerations
for why are these systems on the list and why are they priority
one, safe Houston and public safety is clearly Mayor Turner's top
priority. And one of the things that we look at
when we evaluate the prioritization of It spend is
where there is risk. And in these cases, these equipment,
these systems are all end of life and they pose risk
to the city and the police department.
Thank you, Mr. Butler.
I don't know how to get back to her.
Okay.
Hi, good afternoon. I think you guys do an excellent job. I've just got
a series of questions I'll use in my three minutes and then you can respond.
Can you rank your top three priorities?
And you did to finish up that conversation you just started that
give you the best return on investment, dollar wise for every
dollar you spend? The next question is basically,
how are you guys going to do more with less? Because that's the way you've
painted this picture. It's impressive. I just want to know how you're going to do
the magic trick. The other question is, has the city's IDT
department been affected by the pandemic and the supply chain in slowing down
or hindering either major upgrades or rollouts
or updates that you have? Also, you said you
do travel and connect with other cities. Does the city of Houston rank statewide,
regionally and nationally well and does your
budget reflect managing city the size of Houston?
And lastly, very broad question, how has it
priority shifted for you and why?
May I start to answer those? I don't think I can get to all of
them. Okay, so can you give us Readers
Digest version? Okay, so question number
one top three priorities based on ROI.
We definitely focus on things that pose risk, because if we
don't deal with those, they present themselves as much larger,
much more expensive problems to fix after the fact. Okay, so cyber
is a great example, but so is aging equipment. The next
one, how are we going to do more than with less?
That is a big challenge. Thankfully, we hire
people who like challenges. But in terms of
getting the best bang for the buck, we look to identify
solutions and platforms that solve multiple problems. And so
you will see us identifying, particularly in the areas of applications
that can meet multiple departments needs. We talked about infor earlier.
We have several departments using that permitting and inspection platform.
Supply chain? Yes. It's a huge problem. There are certain pieces
of equipment. I won't name the manufacturer, but we have been
waiting for things that normally we would get in one to two months is taking
more than a year. It's a huge problem.
Priority shift. How have
my priorities shifted since the Pandemic? We have
definitely been pushing city departments to accelerate
their digital transformation. One of the things I'm very proud of from
the city's infrastructure standpoint, and even our
applications portfolio, many of those tools were already there.
What we needed to do is help departments with the business transformation
to be able to really embrace operating digitally
all the way to the end. Customer out in the field.
Thank you. You're welcome. Thank you. And that concludes
this part. And, Director Ken, as your neighbor of mine, my son came
over and messed up my printer. So can you come over later on?
I'll see what I can do.